il se promène au milieu de l'exposition
à l'ombre des forêts puis se fige et se
transforme en arbre voici la forêt
humaine imaginé par les élèves de
l'école de danse d'elancourt une
performance artistique et arborescentes
préparé dans le cadre du festival
courants d'art à la ferme du mousseau la
performance et à un moment on songe où
on se met en jeu avec des moments
d'improvisation justement faire pousser
créer des architectures d'arbres à
partir donc de cette de ce jeu avec le
bras et la main et le regard âgés de 9 à
11 ans et enfants se sont emparés de
l'univers forestier pour créer un poème
des mouvements le bruit des feuilles
accompagnés par les professionnels
cécile oumhani pour la poésie et gilles
verièpe pour la chorégraphie dans la
performance qu'on fait on commence par
faire un parent marché dans tout le dire
comme une forêt après on fait on
commence à faire un arbre thérèse-marie
et les a dit déjà si on avait résidé
balla y avait quelque chose propositions
comme faire des pas de danse à deux
ou alors on danse et comme des feuilles
d'arbres
rendez vous le samedi 23 mars à 16
heures à la ferme du mousseau pour
découvrir la performance des élèves et
le vernissage de l'exposition à l'ombre
des forêts